Coran elympios may not even recall the  incident that reportedly shut down  filming bachelor in paradise this  according to a source close to  production after the hit ABC show halted  production on its fourth season of BI P  due to allegations of misconduct between  Corinne and fellow cast mate - Mario  Jackson a source close to the production  tells ET Corinne says she doesn't  remember much of anything and another  source claims de Mario was heavily  intoxicated as well what happened  between Corinne and de Mario is still  unclear and neither party has filed a  complaint at this time an investigation  is currently underway and many are  questioning whether bachelor in paradise  will be done for good